Here's everything I prepped to make my week just a little bit easier.
I started off by making some Cheez its.
Once the dough came together,
I refrigerated it for about an hour
while I prepped all my other things.
It was time to bake my sour dough bread.
I do about two or three loafs a week.
I scored my bread
and then popped it in the oven for 45 minutes before letting it cool.
We've been having a lot of pasta lately,
so I wanted some sauce handy with that,
so I made a Bolognese.
I started off by chopping some celery,
carrot, onion,
letting that go on the stove before adding my ground meat,
some red wine,
my tomato sauce,
some herbs.
And I always save my Parmesan rinds to pop in my sauce to simmer.
I usually let that simmer anywhere from three to six hours,
but while that was going,
I wanted to make something quick to grab as a snack,
so I made some lemon Poppy seed.
Muffins are perfect for when spring rolls around.
They only take about 15 minutes in the oven.
I also had potatoes that needed to go,
so I boiled them for a couple minutes
before tossing them in my lemon mustard marinade.
And whenever I wanna have them,
I just pull them out and bake them to get them all crispy.
By this time, my dough had chilled enough,
so I rolled it out,
sliced it up, and Assembled all of my little crackers on a baking sheet,
bake them until the edges got brown,
and then transfer them over once they were cooled.
I thought the muffins needed a little lemon glaze,
I mix some lemon juice and powdered sugar to go on top of the muffins,
put half of them away, and the other half were eaten almost immediately.
Also remembered that I got some peaches,
so I wanted to make peach and lime jam.
I didn't want it too thick,
so I found a happy medium
so I could also spread it on top of oatmeal or waffles.
And to grab this Asian pickled cucumber salad. A lot.
So I made a new batch,
seasoned it with some Marin,
sesame oil, chili flakes,
rice wine vinegar,
and put that aside.
Then I transferred my Bolognese over, and this is everything I prepped.